so I know tonight probably didn't go the
way you wanted it to but what have you
learned about yourself doing this show
where do I begin
um
how strong you are yeah I learned how
strong I am because this didn't come
easy to me
dance wise but also emotionally and you
know it brought out like a fear of doing
this you know and through that fear I
kept going I just kept I said no matter
what and I told her every time I'm like
I'm just gonna keep going I'm just gonna
get up and keep chopping away and all
the other factors that we had to deal
with weren't making it any easier
because you know we got lowest scores
all the time and all that so I just like
learned that like I can I can get up I'm
a fighter and I can keep going
and uh your partnership you know you can
tell it's so much fun to watch you guys
is this a partnership that you'll take
into the future as well oh my God yeah
this is the now we can actually be
friends
we had pizza the other night and we're
like this feels wrong we're like let's
rehearse tomorrow we're like having a
Sit yeah you know and it's and that's
what I think my biggest takeaway from
the season was is that I gained like a
forever bro like a forever friend
literally I I don't know I've never
grown so close to somebody and you're
such a short amount every day for the
last three months I don't know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna wake up tomorrow
morning and be like hey minister
so it's just it's amazing actually
throughout the whole thing we never
actually I never felt that I needed like
a break from you like you know what I
mean like anybody would always feel like
all right enough of that person yeah I
felt we would be discouraged about this
but like never like oh man I'm seeing
Coco today
um and then like they send the show
you're the furthest of any Jersey Shore
a cast member I mean how does that feel
and is there another Jersey Shore member
you'd love to see on Dancing With the
Stars like who is it that you'd love to
see
um I don't know if I wish this up on any
of them honestly like I want to be like
yeah you know but uh uh no I yeah I did
make it further which is kind of
shocking but um you know I don't know I
mean I think like Dina would kill it
obviously
yeah Dina would kill it um Paulie
obviously Paulie would go through like a
yeah he has heart and he would go
through like a whole transformation
because this really strips you down of
like what you think you are and then you
come here and it's like no no we're
gonna we're gonna figure out who you
really are inside you know so
um but yeah any of the cast mates can
come out here and do it and then uh
lastly who are you guys sort of pulling
for now that you're out of the
competition I know maybe that's not fair
I don't I literally don't know I'm gonna
give 10 bills to everybody who's left
yeah no um literally each person for
their own reason I could I couldn't even
there's Talent there's heart there's
adversity you know what I'm saying like
Trevor and Daniel like Angela yeah so
however it pans out at this time like
it's anybody's game and I'd be happy
with any outcome I'm literally so happy